so it's now officially June and you'll
know what that means the month of
Father's Day it's also Gay Pride Month
Ilana
so that means we're going to be swimming
in debt girls yes clean I know I think
it's actually the office of this house
we want to wish all of our trans lesbian
gay and gender non-conforming friends a
very happy pride enjoy this brand-new
clip from our movies rough night
all right everybody have a special
request from a caucasian named Rosalie
Travis yeah come on come on through the
drink boys girl get up there we won the
talent show freshman year with the
school routine I might want to stand
back
so basically get back okay
did you go to college with us you're not
in Turkey listen all you ladies
osteo crystalizes check your body don't
stop
shake your body don't stop don't just do
it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're doing
thank you
[Music]
see the money frame
[Applause]
hey anybody see me fall everybody you
spell
okay before we go we got to do human
friends but yeah
what is a human friend paid if the photo
we always take it's like the movie Human
Centipede where they're sewn together
mouth to anus but it's with friends so
it's special I give the middle oh how do
you want the middle this is it your
bachelorette weekend you've been
dreaming about this moment it's the
first day of freshman year we're going
to be swimming and dig girl I just got a
call from The busboy why so everyone's
been telling them I was kind of hoping
that we could make it an early night
this doesn't feel right yeah I don't
think so baby girl put on the [ __ ]
thousand my god I'm so hot
crazy bad you so now you got too much
makeup that can be for your face let's
get the stripper guys male or female
though yeah ma'am I think the male for
her fine
make you feel special oh god no no no no
come on do I know you get the picture
fondue which one you're totally [ __ ]
my picture there was a guy in Australia
who cooked his girlfriend and ate her
you know I can't cuz I am vegan by me
[Music]
I suppose being the best weekend of our
parking lot I probably had HPV now
whenever we all obviously I don't have
HPV if you've had sex after the in 1981
then you do have HPV oh then I have like
a [ __ ] ton of HPV quantum consummate
okay
[Music]
you